according to a new gallup poll race
relations are at a
20-year low the majority of americans 57
say that race relations are somewhat or
very
bad which is amazing to me because
for the past couple of decades all of
our elite institutions
have claimed that all whites are racist
blacks can't leave their homes without
being hunted down
on account of their race and that race
is the single most important aspect
of a person's identity given the
prominence and influence of so many race
hustling hucksters
it's a wonder race relations aren't at
an all-time low
i'm michael knowles is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to my glass half full take
my
favorite comment yesterday is from zoop
defloop
who says they no longer send me updates
when you go live
you've made it thank you very much yes
i'm very pleased about that
youtube is not telling people when my
show is live
the new york times refuses to
acknowledge that speechless
my new book sold more copies than any
other book in the country by about 40
percent
i feel like i feel like i've really hit
something i feel like we're right over
the target you know
this news about the race relations thing
is pretty sad because
i remember i remember back when things
were a little bit better
and i remember in part because i still
have my photos thanks to legacy box
you've got a lot of wonderful photos of
all those priceless memories that can
never be
recreated from years ago decades ago in
some cases some cases even older than
that maybe
and they're sitting in a box somewhere
and you say oh i'll deal with them later
i'll deal with them later well first of
all they're decaying right now
and with legacy box you can just send
them in have them digitized by hand get
the physical photos
and videos back but then also get the
digital copy on a dvd or on a thumb
drive or on the cloud that's great
but then i know what you're thinking
you're saying that's a great idea i
definitely want to do that it's very
important
i'll do it later
order this right now order this right
now you can send them in whenever you
want if you've got a busy week or
something but just order it right now
trust me these are priceless memories
think about all the investments you make
that are
totally you know frivolous invest in
your memories our memories
constitute so much of who we are get
started future proofing your memories
today
so you can gather the family begin the
trip down memory lane go to
legacybox.com
knowles to get an incredible 40 off your
first order
get it today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer 40 off go to
legacybox.com
save 40 while supplies last race
relations are at an all-time low now
what the
libs will tell you the libs who have
dominated every institution for decades
now what they will tell you is
the reason race relations are at an
all-time low is because we're not
talking about race enough
we're not having enough conversations
about race
we're not focused on race enough now of
course
the strategy for the past 20 years has
been to focus
more and more and more on race and to
push anti-racism
and the consequences of critical race
theory
and various other leftist programs so
the the proof of the pudding tends to be
in the tasting
the consequence of all of these racially
conscious
new new ideas seems to be a decline in
race relations and yet
what the libs are going to tell us is
that this is just evidence that we need
even more of their racial theories
that sort of like how the the ibram
candy types the anti-racist types
beg the question sort of how they say
well
look if you deny that you are a racist
that is only evidence
that you are a racist and obviously if
you admit that you're a racist that's
evidence that you're a racist so either
way
you need to buy my book pretty brilliant
marketing campaign
my point though on why we
don't need to talk about race all the
time why it's detrimental to do that
is because there are other bad things
there are other bad things in the world
than racism
for instance so pit viper which it makes
the
sunglasses from the 90s you remember
those the colorful sunglasses
they are in a bind they've been
receiving a lot of pressure
from leftist groups because apparently
some evil terrible no-good racists
have worn pit vipers so they've they
just they wore the sunglasses
and so pit vipers needs to make a
statement they made a statement
specifically
against the guy nick fuentes he we've
mentioned him on the show a few times
who has said plenty of unsavory things
and has been
entirely unpersoned because of it you
know there are a lot of people who say
unsafe readings in this country
who don't end up on the no-fly list and
kicked off of all major social media
and not permitted to use financial
institutions
but because of his unsavory things he he
has been uh un-person so
pitviper sent out a tweet they said new
policy money received from confirmed
racists
will be donated in their name thanks for
working against your cause nick fuentes
and they donated to the southern poverty
law center which is a vicious vile
hate group if you ask me uh one of the
worst organizations in the country
okay so the money that comes from the
racists that's gonna
that's unacceptable we won't keep that
money we're gonna donate it to other
groups
are there other bad bad groups of people
in the country so okay the racists
they're bad
okay fine got it racists they're bad
what about the communists what if
you get money pit vipes what if you get
money from
confirmed communists are you going to
keep that money
communism killed 100 million people in
the 20th century
vicious anti-human ideology
i guess you'll keep that kind of money
what about uh uh money from guys who
cheat on their wives
is that's bad it's bad to cheat on your
wife are you you're gonna take money
from guys who
who cheat on their wives what about um
pedophile confirms pedophiles
i bet that's some confirmed pedophiles
have worn
sunglasses at some point in their lives
you're going to take money from them
what about abortionists oh my god you're
going to take money for hold on i get it
you don't want to take money from
racists
but you're gonna take money from people
whose job it is to murder babies
a lot of bad people out there a lot of
bad things out there
but the only way that we can talk
about evil and sin in this country
anymore
is by talking about racism it's
considered the only bad
thing just like how among political
movements
fascism is the only bad thing this is
why sometimes
people will refer to antifa as fascists
or they'll refer to democrats as
fascists they're not fascists
antifa is made up of communists and
anarchists and those are very bad people
but they're actually not
fascists and by by pretending
that the political movement that is only
ever associated with the right wing that
that's the only
bad thing in the world that
plays to the leftists hand
speaking of communists by the way
governor ron desantis he's not a
communist but governor ron desantis now
is clearly making a play for the 2024
presidential nomination
he's looking down what's going on 90
miles off the coast of florida
and he is saying the united states ought
to free cuba
from day one the people of cuba have
been protesting and demonstrating
against
the communist dictatorship in havana
it's not because of vaccines it's not
because of these side issues
they want a new government they want to
free cuba and
it's i think incumbent upon us and in
the united states uh to be supportive of
those efforts i've called on joe biden
the communist regime has shut down
internet let's work to beam internet
onto the island of cuba so these folks
have a fighting chance
to converse with one another to send
what's going on to the outside world
let's build an international coalition
uh so that the regime knows free world
stands with the people of cuba
i think you're seeing people take to the
streets here because we understand
after 62 years something is different on
that island right now
we have an opportunity to really take a
new chapter in history and i think you
point out in your monologue
cuba would be a phenomenal ally of our
country if it was free
they would boom like probably few
countries in the caribbean it would be
uh a boon for the people of cuba and it
would also be
great for relations with the united
states so this
will play very well for ron desantis in
florida don't forget he's going to win a
gubernatorial election before he can
he's got to win re-election there before
he can run for president so this will
play very well obviously lots of cubans
in miami
a lot of people very supportive to the
people of cuba against the communist
regime
i'm not so sure that this kind of thing
plays nationally though this would have
played nationally
five to 15 years ago really actually
five years ago to
i don't know 50 years ago back when
anti-communism was the rallying cry of
the conservative movement
and and especially after the fall of the
berlin wall when regime change was sort
of the name of the game
on the republican side but i'm not
convinced
that the american people want to form
any international coalitions to push for
any sort of regime change anywhere in
the world
not because it's intrinsically wrong to
do that in any way but because
the american people are kind of tired of
those regime change wars of empire
i think they're tired i mean the
republican candidate
ran against the war in iraq ran against
remaining in afghanistan in 2016 and
2020 i guess for that matter
we're just pulling out of afghanistan
now this is the first thing i mean look
i'm i'm with desantis
on standing against the communist
dictatorship but the overt calls for an
international movement to go in and
institute regime change i'm not sure
that that is the political moment we're
in because there's so many problems here
in the united states
that are not even just economic problems
or not even looming problems of
debt say or unfunded entitlements but
real problems of crime in the streets
spiking as we said race relations
lowest in 20 years we've got people
burning down
buildings we've got people who don't
trust our electoral systems
you know a lot of problems here in the
united states and i strongly suspect
that the candidate in 2024 the
republican nominee in 2024
is going to have a pretty strong
domestic focus obviously
circumstances can change in the world so
who knows some unforeseen event
involving china or some other
geopolitical actor maybe that could
change things
but as of right now i think the focus is
going to be domestic for the people
who run for the republican or who win
the republican nomination
in 2024 and we're gonna have to pick
that candidate all right we're gonna
have to find the best person for the job
and when you want to find the best
person for the job
i would recommend zip recruiter as an
employer by far the most difficult
challenge you're gonna face the most
consequential decision you're gonna make
is personnel who you hire
that is gonna make or break your company
okay and hiring can feel like trying to
find a needle in a haystack
so okay you can do the old old-fashioned
way where you post your job to some job
board
and you throw spaghetti at the wall and
you just hope that the right person
comes along
or you can do it the smart way go to
ziprecruiter right now for free
ziprecruiter.com you post a job on zip
recruit or get sent out
to over 100 top job sites with one click
then zip recruiters matching technology
will find the right people with the
right skills and experience
for your job and actively invite them to
apply
zip recruiters so effective that four
out of five employers who post there get
a quality candidate within the first day
no wonder over 2.3 million businesses
have come to ziprecruiter for their
hiring needs while other
companies overwhelm you with way too
many options ziprecruiter finds you what
you're looking for the needle in the
haystack and right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com knowles
that is ziprecruiter.comcnwlis
ziprecruiter
the smartest way to hire ron desantis
more than any governor in the country
generally speaking has his finger on the
pulse of
where the republican party is right now
he's seen things a little bit ahead
obviously he's making this play right
now for a cuban vote in florida
and he's standing against the communists
which is a little maybe out of step
with where the republican party is
because of this domestic focus i think
the republicans have right now but
generally speaking he's ahead on these
things
and i think you might start to see a
shift
in the way that the covid vaccine is
talked about
ron desantis has led the covet fight
better than any other governor in the
country desantis now is
actively encouraging people to go get
the covid vaccines
if you are vaccinated fully vaccinated
the chance of you getting seriously ill
or dying from covid
is effectively zero if you look at the
people that are being admitted to
hospitals
uh over 95 percent of them are either
not fully vaccinated or not vaccinated
at all and so
these vaccines are saving lives they are
reducing mortality
mortality in nursing homes since we
rolled out the vaccines in december is
down over 95 percent
due to covid mortality for elderly
people since we rolled out the vaccines
is down
nearly 90 percent and so we're proud in
florida that we put seniors first on
that because they were the most
vulnerable
we have 85 percent of our seniors that
are vaccinated and about 75 percent of
folks
over the age of 50. we have no mandate
we've provided information to people um
and and we've
been very honest about any data that
that comes out
so fair enough that's fine the the only
problem i have with this
statement and this new pivot among
republicans to start really pushing the
vaccine
not with mandates he's done a good job
of saying no we're not going to have a
mandate
but still act really encouraging people
to go get it
is it hides the ball
on the question of prudence it hides the
ball on the question of
which demographics are most at risk here
because you're going to hear this
statistic 99.9999
of people who go to the hospital for
covid are unvaccinated now and so you
all need to get the vaccine get the
vaccine sheep
but then notice what governor desantis
says he says
the nursing home mortality from kovid he
has to say from kovid because nursing
home mortality is you know 100
mortality for everyone is 100 in the
long run he says
nursing home fatality mortality from
covid has dropped 95 percent
since among people who got the vaccine
oh yeah of course that makes sense
mortality among the elderly from covet
has dropped 95 percent
for those who got the vaccine yeah that
makes sense
does that mean that a 18 year old needs
to go get the vaccine
or should get the vaccine no that
doesn't follow
logically at all from the very beginning
there have been people who have said
everyone needs to go get the vaccine
immediately there have been people who
said no one should ever touch that
vaccine because they're going to get 5g
in their bodies and then their cell
phones are going to work too well
that's not my position my position is
use
prudence this is an experimental drug it
received an emergency youth
use authorization there are side effects
that we were initially not told about
that then presented themselves that then
the cdc and the fda had to acknowledge
namely blood clots from the johnson and
johnson vaccine in women mostly women
and myocarditis and periocarditis in
young people who are otherwise healthy
from some of the mrna vaccines
plus a rare nervous system disorder
that came from the johnson johnson
vaccine that's also been present
from other vaccines
slowly they had to acknowledge those
risks if you are in a nursing home
probably the risk from covid is greater
than the risk from the vaccine
especially if we're talking about
potential long-term side effects because
if you're in a nursing home the long
term is not your concern to quote the
great
not actually not so great economist john
maynard keynes in the long run we're all
dead
if you are 15 years old
why would you get this vaccine
here's the real answer you might get
this vaccine because your school makes
you and then you've got to make a choice
or you're going to remain in the school
or not you're going to have to make a
political decision there
but from a medical perspective there is
why on earth would you get the vaccine
there was that story of a 13 year old
who died just days after receiving the
vaccine from inflammation of the heart
not saying that correlation is causation
but
seems kind of coincidental doesn't it
and so that
that is the issue here because the
people who are going into hospitals the
you know huge numbers of people that
we're told are going into hospitals with
coronavirus it's actually not a very
large number of people
relative to the people who have been
infected by it but it's not
generally speaking 15 and 18 and 25 year
olds it's
much elder more much older people
rather and so when you're making that
decision i think
prudence is the answer and so you're
going to start see
seeing even republican politicians start
pushing this vaccine
i think we've still got to focus on
prudence that's going to be the answer
that is that is the conservative virtue
now
gensake at the white house is attacking
ron desantis not over his
new measures to push the vaccine more
and more but because the man is not
doing enough because he won't
institute a vaccine mandate or a mass
mandate
florida governor de sanchez was talking
about mass mandates for kids
earlier this morning and he said we're
not doing that in florida we need our
kids to breathe
we need our kids to be able to be kids
he said it's terribly uncomfortable for
them to do it
that obviously goes against the cdc
guidance for kids under 12 who aren't
vaccinated and what the president said
last night
is that putting kids in florida at risk
well as a parent myself and i know you
are one if i were a parent in florida
that would be
greatly concerning to me because kids
under the age of 12
are not vaccinated they're not eligible
yet as the president said last night
obviously it's going to be led by the
fda but
certainly we hope that will be soon but
that puts kids at risk it's not aligned
with public health guidelines
we know masks are not the most
comfortable thing
i will say my kids are quite adjusted to
them as i know many kids are
so certainly we would have concern about
any step that doesn't abide by public
health guidelines and we think it puts
people
at greater risk so you've gotta you've
got to put your seven-year-old in a mask
or else you're
you're harming the public health because
you understand the vaccine is extremely
effective so
it's so effective that if your
six-year-old doesn't wear a mask
all the vaccinated people are going to
die from the virus that doesn't pose a
particularly large risk to
to most people gensake
is i think being pretty disingenuous
here
i don't think that the public health
geniuses
and the politicians who are pushing the
mask mandates and the vaccine mandates
in some cases
and the strong push for the vaccines and
the lockdowns and all the like
i don't think they're all that concerned
about coronavirus i don't think they
think the coronavirus is
nearly as big a deal as they have led on
here's my evidence of that
the texas democrats who fled
the state because they didn't want to do
their job and
have to recognize that the people of
texas want voter integrity laws
they fled the state on an airplane
without wearing any masks
because they're not afraid of
coronavirus because no one's really
afraid of coronavirus because except for
a few demographics of people
most people don't face a great risk from
coronavirus
they then got a lot of coronavirus they
go to dc they mill about with members of
pelosi staff with
legislators on capitol hill with members
of the white house and now some of those
people in the white house
have come down with coronavirus if this
were the greatest public health threat
we've ever faced we would need those
numbers
certainly gensake would be telling us
those numbers but because it's not
she won't it's been a couple of days
since we talked about the breakthrough
case
on the campus here and that you
acknowledged there were additional
breakthrough cases can you give us now
the number of breakthrough cases that
have occurred
during the biden presidency well i would
say first that
um our medical experts our health
experts have been conveying from the
beginning as have we that there would be
cases of individuals who are vaccinated
who uh tested positive for covid
uh there are 2 000 people who work on
the campus
and of course so that means that just
statistically speaking there will be
people who
are vaccinated individuals who get
coveted on
the campus what i announced yesterday or
conveyed yesterday was
what our policy would be moving forward
but
no i don't think you can expect that
we're going to be providing numbers of
breakthrough cases no
on the one hand this is hypocritical
because whenever
any conservative gets coveted that left
makes a big deal about this whenever
anyone in a conservative state
gets coveted the left makes a big deal
about this so yes it's hypocritical on
the other hand
yeah of course they don't need to give
us the numbers it's not that big a deal
their people are fine
they're fine okay i know are you allowed
to say that i don't know but i'm going
to say that
unless you're in a particularly at-risk
group from coronavirus
it's fine we don't need to report on how
many people are getting it we don't need
to
we don't even need to report on how many
people are going to the doctor from this
because
overwhelmingly they're recovering just
fine you saw the numbers yesterday in
australia
188 000 tests for coronavirus
and then what was it 800 some odd people
who have got coronavirus and then one
person died from coronavirus so we're
going to lock down the country that
doesn't make any
sense that's madness absolute
madness and it's not even the craziest
thing gensake has been talking about
i actually i think this is one of the
more reasonable takes that jensaki in
the white house has had
no we're not going to tell you how many
people have coronavirus because it just
doesn't matter it's fine it's a cough
for most people okay and then and
they're already vaccinated and so
that kind of contradicts the narrative
that the vaccine is extremely effective
and and it's going to prevent you from
getting coronavirus
anyway what the
white house is much more concerned about
than controlling the spread of
coronavirus is controlling the narrative
so that even when the guidance changes
from all the genius experts
even when the new rules and the mandates
and the restrictions change
they are going to be able to control the
flow of information
and the white house is making an even
larger play
than they have been in recent weeks in
recent weeks they have been pressuring
social media
to take a greater hand of censorship of
conservatives
they've been pressuring social media to
institute more serious punishments
now they're saying that if you were
banned from one social media platform
you should be banned from all of the
platforms jen
saki asked this question about whether
or not
the white house is pushing this kind of
stuff
if the white house is going to continue
to
wield its political power to censor
people on social media
she says you're damn right a couple of
the steps that we have
um you know that could be constructive
for the public health
uh of the country are uh providing
uh for for facebook or other platforms
to measure and publicly share the impact
of misinformation on their platform
and the audience it's reaching also with
the public
with all of you to create robust
enforcement strategies that bridge their
properties and provide transparency
about rules you shouldn't be banned from
one platform
and not others if you affor
providing misinformation out there
taking faster
action against harmful posts remember
donald trump's lawsuit against big tech
as they violated his first amendment
rights the only way that this lawsuit
works is if
they can prove that the government is
pressuring social media to act as a
proxy for the government to censor
people and gensake is doing that
consider how crazy this is she's saying
that if you are ostracized if you
violate the rule on one social media
platform
you need to be completely kicked out of
the public square you need to be
completely ostracized like this is
ancient imperial athenian democracy
okay you need to be completely kicked
out and that is what is happening
increasingly and the people who wield
the power are going to decide usually in
a
somewhat arbitrary or capricious way who
gets booted from the public square
speaking of unpersonal people nancy
pelosi is a novel
religious idea she has a novel religious
idea that one can be a devout catholic
and support abortion it's an issue of
health
of many women in america especially
those
in lower income situations and in
different states and it is something
that has been
a priority for many of us a long time uh
as a
devout catholic and mother of five in
six years
uh i uh feel that god blessed my husband
and me with our beautiful family five
children six years almost to the day
but that may not be what we should it's
not up to me to
dictate that that's what other people
should do
and it's an issue of fairness and
justice for poor women in in our country
so one it is up to you you're a
legislator you're the speaker of the
house it's up to you to make the laws
two
you're saying pretty ghastly thing that
you a nice rich lady should be able to
have a lot of kids but for poor people
they need to kill their kids so that
they can go work in the widget factory
or whatever but then to the religious
claim she says i'm a devout catholic but
i support abortion and the thing is
this is not just my opinion this is the
opinion of the catholic church
which we can know which is made public
you cannot be an abortion supporter
and a devout catholic at the same time
i'm going to you remember in 7th or 8th
grade you learned about rules of logic
do you remember you learned the contra
positive this is one of those things
people learn when they're a kid and they
forget
the contra positive is this if if you
have
if p then q
right then if not q
then not p this your teacher wrote this
on the board
when you were in middle school so to
give you a lesson on the contra positive
on contra position
if you are a devout catholic
then you do not support abortion
if you support abortion then you are not
a devout catholic
qed there you are thank you for
attending my lecture
on contra position so now some people
have said michael how dare you you can't
judge people
i'm not judging her i'm i'm not damning
her
or sending her up to heaven i i don't
have the power to do that but i can
judge the teaching of the church because
the church's teaching is public
and what nancy pelosi is doing right
here is committing a public sin it's the
sin of scandal
she's also lying a private senten would
be say if nancy pelosi goes home at
night and drinks three bottles of wine
and then i gossip around and i could
start spreading these rumors or
something
or a private sin is she goes and cheats
on her husband or whatever
you see what she's committing is a
public sin and she's making a claim that
is demonstrably false
it is not possible to be a devout
catholic if you support
abortion now thankfully the house gop
is defunding or is is now trying to
defund universities
that provide chemical abortions this is
very good stuff being pushed by
representatives mary miller
chip roy and steve danes
that steve danes obviously in the united
states senate co-sponsoring legislation
in response to this 2019 california bill
that would provide chemical abortion
pills to students at the beginning of
2023
what what the congress is saying now is
they're going to defund them if they do
this that's very very good use of the
law there's also really good news here
on the
pro-life front mississippi attorney
general lynn
fitch is now asking the supreme court of
the united states
to overturn roe versus wade and planned
parenthood v casey which was the
affirmation of roe versus wade
these were two of the most unprincipled
preposterous
unconstitutional decisions in the
history of the united states
very probably the two worst decisions
ever made in the history of
the court and there's a case right now
working its way up the courts
it will be heard by the supreme court
it's dobbs v
jackson women's health organization
this is the first major abortion case to
be heard by the current court
it's going to be ruled on in the spring
of 2022
and at issue is going to be a
mississippi law prohibiting abortions
after 15 weeks at 15 weeks a baby in the
womb can suck its own thumb okay
so the blob of cells argument is not
really going to work very well here
very very important stuff okay now
speaking of little boys and little girls
before we go i do want to mention and
we'll get into this a little bit later
on
that the girl scouts right now the girl
scouts of america
are pushing an anti-racism guy they're
pushing a guide that is being formed by
critical race theory
and these kind of insane leftist race
racial views
a missouri school district right now is
paying
15 000 to a critical race theory
professor
for an audit of the curriculum don't let
them tell you that
that critical race theory is not being
taught in elementary schools and middle
schools okay
that is the focus but there are a lot of
other problems in this country
you know killing babies that can suck
their own thumb that seems like a big
problem
you know of forcing people to take
experimental drugs if they're not at
great risk of a virus shutting down the
whole country shutting down our churches
taking away people's constitutional
rights that's that's a big problem
those are big problems too there are
more problems i think than just race and
if we're only going to focus on race
then i know it seems paradoxical to
people on the left
but actually racial relations are going
to hit
decades long lows not
very good stuff maybe we should focus on
some of the other problems too and then
maybe we'll have a country
that that improves across all of these
levels
the podcast that has just hit what hit
number two i think
on the charts would happen to be daily
wire's own morning wire
it is number two on apple podcast charts
it's number 11 on spotify
we're really happy about this but
it's not enough it's not enough we want
it to go up higher subscribe now to
morning wire on apple spotify wherever
you listen to your podcasts leave a
five-star review if you like what you
hear it's a really terrific show
also as an all-access member you can now
be a part of the candace show
live studio audience in the daily wire
or headquarters of nashville
head on over to dailywire.com tickets
today to pick up yours
and after you order speechless
controlling words controlling minds
you can pre-order ben's new book it's
coming out on tuesday
you can reorder a signed copy for 30
bucks dailywire.com ben
the book is called the authoritarian
moment also my campaign slogan
head on over there uh you'll be able to
when you when you pre-order this book
put a question in the in the computer
screen
you will then hopefully have your
question answered by ben himself on
tuesday
that is the authoritarian moment a great
uh book title and a great campaign
slogan head on over there right now
we'll be right back with the mailbag
first question up from jd who says dear
connecticut casanova
thank you for recognizing one of my real
titles
i dated a girl for a little over five
years starting in college and going into
my first few years of working life she
broke up with me a while ago
but we continued a sexual relationship
for about one year after that
during this time i was blocked on her
social media man good grief
and was therefore unaware that she had a
serious boyfriend throughout the time we
were together
she sounds like a pip when i became
aware i severed all ties
recently she texted me out of the blue
and confessed that she wants me back and
still loves me
uh-huh she this love apparently caused
her to leave that guy to be with me
or to be alone maybe i guess are you
still blocked on social media she might
have another few guys in the corner
i have a girlfriend that is a
red-blooded conservative that i'm
incredibly happy with
the question is not who to pick i know
my ex-girlfriend is bad for me but my
question is how do i get rid of this
feeling that she is right for me
and that i should be with her it's not
fair to myself or my girlfriend to be
hung up on a past lover sincerely yours
way too nerdy to be this wanted
this problem afflicts a great many this
might afflict every single guy
it's the problem of what if it's the
problem of the one that got away it's
the problem
of shall i really lock myself down i
could do this i could do that
it's the problem of infatuation which is
different than love
infatuation is when you are obsessed
with
an idea and it can feel a lot like love
i mean it can you know writers going
back to
ancient days have written about this
feeling of love sickness your heart
feels like it really hurts but you know
that this is not
ordered properly you know this is not
the right thing obviously in the case of
this trumpet that you
you were dating before who's cheating on
her boyfriend with you and who knows how
many other guys
uh yes you're right obviously you should
stay with your girlfriend
you just gotta deal with it buddy get
over your feels get over all the feels
man one
one thing that might cure it is getting
married
one thing that mike here i don't know if
you're ready to get married yet or
anything like that but
if you just make a decision
and say okay this is my choice i'm
making this choice it's a public choice
this chickie is over and i i might still
have feelings and i might still oh i
still
but what if and i might you might i
don't even mean to make fun of you too
much but
you might you might still dream about
this girl you might still think about
her you might still say what if what if
okay that's life buddy get over it make
a decision sometimes a wrong decision
even is better than
indecision though in this case it sounds
like
sticking with your good conservative
girlfriend is is a way better idea
than this harlot that you had previously
been dating
but what can i do michael what can i do
i still have feelings
you can act like a man what's the matter
with you
best of luck from john dear michael the
olympics are about to kick into full
gear
my question is will you be watching the
games and what competition do you think
is the best and which is the most
ridiculous pointless besides women's
soccer
no i won't be watching the games not
even because of all the
un-american people who are supposed to
be representing our country
like the hammer throwing girl or
whatever the women's soccer team or you
know i
i also just don't like the olympics i
don't care about the olympics at all i'm
not interested in it
i guess i hope we win except for the
women's side except for the people who
hate our country who are on our team i
hope they lose
but i hope that the people who like our
country win i guess but i just don't
care
i don't i've never seen a soccer game in
my life whether it's women or men and i
just don't
i don't care the one sport i like in the
olympics as i
as always there's an exception there's a
caveat the one sport i like
is curling i do i really like it i get a
kick out of it i think it's a whimsical
funny sport to watch
so i i might turn that on but otherwise
no i probably will not be watching
from liam dear connoisseur of course you
have spoken at length
of how the political left has made a
religion of science has the political
right made a religion of america's
founding
i ask because one will often hear
members of the political right say john
adams says such and such and
the constitution says this and that in
the same way that christians argue saint
paul says such and such and the gospels
say this and that
also you often quote cardinal manning
saying that all human conflict is
ultimately theological
do you as a practicing catholic have
political disagreements with the
protestant founding fathers
respectfully as somewhat practicing
catholic yes very astute observation
we do have a civic religion
this is not an accident this is not even
insidious necessarily abraham lincoln
called for the development of a civic
religion and i think
all states to some degree have a civic
religion
so in in our country the president
is the pope and the senators are the
cardinals and the founding fathers are
the are the church fathers
and and there are other doctors of the
of the church of the civic religion and
that of course that's true
because politics ultimately is
theological so of course
there are going to be parallels here do
i have disagreements with the founding
fathers yeah i have some disagree i mean
by the way the founding fathers are not
a monolith so in some cases i
agree with hamilton more than i would
agree with adams in some cases
vice versa i generally would agree with
adams and hamilton and washington more
than i would with jefferson but
jefferson made some good points too so
yes
these people are not a monolith one can
have some disagreements with them
in some cases i have strong
disagreements with james mattis and in
other cases madison you know
made very good points uh it is important
i think to have respect for your
founding fathers and and have respect
for the great statesman of your history
and have respect for your tradition and
have love for your country
i don't think that's evil or unjust or
idolatrous or anything like that
love of country is an extension of
filial piety of the of the love of your
own family
and if we don't love the men who gave us
our country then
uh we're we don't love our country right
then we don't love our history then we
don't
we don't love ourselves and we need to
have a healthy love of our country
if we want to survive that said
i think you're absolutely right we must
have true religion as well
otherwise people will make an idol and a
religion out of
politics and that's bad whether it
happens on the left and on the right so
if you have a healthy love of country
and you care about things that john
adams said and you care about things
that
the constitution say and you have that
in its proper place
beneath say love of god and respect for
the eternal
moral order then that's a very good
thing
but it reminds me of chesterton's point
that heresy usually is not the promotion
of vice
or instead of virtue but it's the
promotion of one virtue to the exclusion
of all of the other virtues you don't
you don't that is what idolatry is right
you don't want to make
an idol out of those things very
perceptive question from nick
hey michael me again oh nick oh gosh
i'm having trouble in my place of work
as a practicing basic
dude my goals have always been to date
women slightly above my appearance level
fair enough and have guys invite me to
byob parties on saturdays yeah it's fun
to hang with the boys
the problem is now that i've started
dating someone who i believe
is at least a seven i have not been
invited out with the boys
in some time my question is does this
always happen when a lion is tamed
by a slightly above average lioness or
can you also maintain relationships and
time with the boys
thanks sincerely the ascendants are
getting tricky so i'd just like to say
monica lewinsky you know i'm not going
to finish reading that
i'm not not going to read lewd comments
about monica lewinsky on this show
you know nick you've had colorful
questions in the past and i
and this is no different but it makes a
good point sometimes
men they're cool guys and they'll hang
out with the dudes and then
they start dating a girl and things
change and maybe it's that you guys
don't like the girl
or maybe it's that you you are changing
with the girl and you're becoming
like a a wuss or so i don't this happens
sometimes to guys
or you're allowing yourself to be led
let along by her and you're not assuming
a role of leadership
in the relationship that can happen and
you're going to have to look at yourself
in the mirror
and make sure that you keep some balance
because well it's very obvious it's very
important
to develop a good and healthy
relationship and settle down
nick if i can
bring together some of your other
mailbag questions that seems to be a
problem for you nick
so you're going to want to do that but
you're also going to want to have
balance in your life and you've got to
make some time
for the boys you absolutely have to do
that and if you
give yourself wholly just to this
lioness who is a seven as you say
or you you know you ignore the women and
you just hang with the boys like a
derelict all the time
neither of those are going to be
conducive to human flourishing
you want some balance moderation is a
virtue
from jen hi michael i was hearing you
saying that you didn't want to live in a
world where women were sent to fight our
wars in yesterday's show
yep i'm a young woman in her 30s with a
learning disability i could never fight
i'm too sensitive and i agree with you
that men and women are different
do you believe that women should not
fight in the army and whatnot
i would like to hear your thoughts on
this i think there can be a role for
women
in the armed forces and and there always
has been
to some degree you know there have been
women who have
provided support to the soldiers and
played plenty of roles in the military
but i do not support a political regime
that sends women into combat not even
because women can't do it in some cases
women can do it though obviously women
are less physically
strong than men that's just a fact of
nature
my issue is one from nature and and one
from politics
i don't want to live in a world in which
we are sending our women
to go be shot and maimed and died to
protect us men i just think it's wrong
it's ugly it's a it's a that's a
disordered country
and we need to stop doing it and the
sickos
who are suggesting that women need to
register for the draft
need to be chased out of public life
from
andrew hey michael i'm hearing
republicans for a long time now say
how the internet and social media is the
new public square and should be a place
for freedom of speech if you draw that
to its logical conclusion public square
is a place that you can speak on for
free
we all have the internet but the
internet is not free
if the republicans are arguing that the
internet is a place for freedom of
speech
doesn't that conclude that the internet
is a public square should be free or tax
payer funded at the least as the streets
are thanks love your show and all that
you do
no i don't think so i don't think that
that the internet should be fun
funded by taxpayers i mean the internet
was developed by the way with a lot of
money from taxpayers
but let's just use the example of the
physical public square
traditionally people live a while away
from the public square if you live in
the country
if you you know then you would have to
get a horse you'd have to get a wagon
you'd have to get some way of driving to
the public square so that that cost
would be on you that's not
your wagon and horse are not funded by
the taxpayers if you want to spread your
message in the public square you'd have
to print
flyers or pamphlets that's not funded by
taxpayers
uh if you wanted to to uh really engage
in that way there is some cost to you
and there is some cost
to the public right now it's very easy
to get on the internet there are plenty
of public resources to do that including
the public library
so it's an interesting question but i i
don't i don't think that
in any way the implication is that the
internet should be
totally funded by the taxpayers and i
don't see i don't see how that argument
works
from camille hey michael i watched a
jordan peterson interview where he
explains that intelligent women
tend to have a harder time finding a man
i think this goes along with the
do men value humor in a woman question
from last week that was a good question
and whether men find significant value
in these qualities
this seems unfair but alas life is not
fair i know men and women are different
but what are your thoughts on this
sentiment
i think sometimes women can be too picky
and place too much value
on menial qualities but for us
level-headed women
what is your advice side note not saying
i'm the smartest woman out there but
clearly as an avid listener of your show
my intelligence is quite admirable i
would have to agree
sincerely please don't tell me smart
means settle well i really like
smart women i you know sometimes
how do i put this delicately there are
women
who make an idol out of their
intelligence or
they think that their only quality their
most important quality is
is their intelligence and so you know if
they have bad luck with guys they'll say
you just can't handle a smart woman you
can't handle an ambitious woman you get
something like that right
no i i love smart women i have
i think exclusively not exclusively i've
almost exclusively dated some more women
i married a very intelligent woman
and so i i really like that but there
are other qualities actually getting
back to the top of our show we say
racism is bad okay
sure but there are other bad things too
right it's not the only bad thing
and so intelligence is a good quality
yes but there are other qualities too
your grace your kindness how nurturing
you are how
what sort of sense of humor you have
your physical looks too i mean that's
not that's not irrelevant
your uh dignity your
cultivation i mean all of these things
matter so no i i think intelligent women
are fabulous i love them
um but there are other things in the
world too and i think you need to one
needs to be a balanced person cultivate
all of these things
similar to the answer to nick although
you camille i think are probably a far
more upstanding individual than nick
that's our show
i'm michael knowles as the michael
knowles show see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary our technical director
is austin stevens supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here editor-in-chief of the
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the tokyo olympics
officially kick off
hollywood attempts a box office comeback
and the new space race begins
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know
with our show morning wire